Merhaba arkadaşlar hoşgeldiniz
Ben Engin Hepileri tiyatro oyuncusu ve
yönetmeliyim
1978 İstanbul doğumluyum
bugün burada olmak benim için çok
heyecan verici Çünkü açıkçası birazdan
Size anlatacaklarım Aynen böyle bir
konferans salonunda başladı Benim
hayallerim Ve hayallerime ulaşmak için
yola çıkışım Ben çalışmanın mutluluğu
demek istedim Çünkü
çalıştıkça öğrendikçe
Aslında insanın nasıl mutlu
olabileceğine dair bazı küçük
tüyolar almaya başladım hayattan ve bu
tüyoları da aslında nasıl bulabilirim
nereden çözebilirim ve nasıl devam
ettirebilirim derken işte açıkçası
birazcık Haylaz bir lise hayatım
ortaokul hayatım vardı biraz hareketli
bir çocuktum çok samimi olacağım size
işte böyle büyük laflar etmeyi Ben de
sevmem Biraz önceki iki güzel mütevazı
konuşma hepimizin de söylediği gibi Eee
derslerden Kaçmak için bir kol aradım
kendime Nereye gitsem acaba falan O
aralarda büyük abilerimden birkaç tanesi
tiyatro kolundaydı tiyatro kolumda
oldukları için de galiba onlar böyle
önemli bayramlarda işte Ne vereyim 19
Mayıs'ta 18 Mart'ta ya da 23 Nisan'da
etkinlikler yapılırdı Bizim okulumuzda
ve derslerden böyle izin belgeler
alırlardı ama bak dedim güzel bir yol
Aslında dersten Kaçmak için yani şöyle
söyleyeyim dersi sevmediğimden değil
bazı dersleri sevmediğimden böyle bir
yol aradım kendime o küçük genç aklımla
ve sonra dedim ki neler var işte Kızılay
kolu var tiyatro okulu var tiyatro
kullanıyor tiyatro Kulu olabilir Ne
olabilir yani değişik bir şey ne acaba
gidelim görelim diye girdim
girdiğim anda bir anda şöyle bir şeyle
karşılaştım
içeride böyle sizin yaşınızdaki
arkadaşlarım kitaplar okuyorlar şiirler
okuyorlar şairlerle tanışıyorlar
birbirlerini anlatıyorlar Herkes bir
hafta bir oyun okuyor ertesi hafta kendi
birbirlerini anlatıyorlar
derken ufak ufak sahnelemeler başlıyor
sahnelemeler sırasında anlıyoruz ki
aslında
sahne pek çok sanatı içine alıyor işte
şimdi şu Işıklar mesela çok daha ilginç
çok daha güzel bir şekilde yapılsa
estetik bir şey ortaya çıkacak demek ki
ışık var bu işin içinde ben size
anlatırken vücut kullanımla ya da ne
bileyim bir dansla anlatabilirsem işte
dans var bu işin içinde belki alttan bir
müzik verebilirim ve O müziğin
coşkusuyla başka coşka coşkulara
ulaşabilirim Aa bak Demek ki Müzik de
var bu işin içinde edebiyat var bu işin
içinde tiyatro var oyunculuk var En
temelinde ortada bir baktım ki tiyatro
Aslında böyle bütün sanatları kavrayan
bambaşka bir şeyi ve o dersten
kaytarmaya çalışan çocuk bir anda böyle
büyülenir bir halde sahnede olanları
izlemeye başladım ve sonra dedim ki Ben
de orada olmak istiyorum Peki ben orada
olmak için ne yapmam gerekiyor Bunun
cevabını İşte o çözümleri aramaya
başladım çok
şanslıydım ki iyi bir okulda Canan
Anadolu Lisesi'nde okudum ve o okulda da
çok önemli tiyatro sanatçıları gelirdi
tiyatro Okulu ile beraber bütün bir sene
oyunları çalışıp Daha sonra da sahneler
nerede arkadaşlarım
benim de gerçekten çok Değerli hocalarım
oldu ve onlar sayesinde de yavaş yavaş
böyle sahneye adım atmaya başladım hatta
kendi dekorumu çaktığımı kendi
müziklerimizi kendimiz yaptığımızı falan
da hatırlıyorum hiç unutmayacağım günler
geçirmiştim
lise yıllarında Hatta şöyle bir şey de
oldu oradaki o yaramaz çocuğun bir anda
dönüşüp evde de bir anda ben böyle
tiyatro konuşuyorum Ne bileyim işte
kolda bunları yapıyoruz diyen bir adam
haline dönüşüverdim bir anda buna ben
tabii ki Sanatın iyileştirici Gücü ve
diyorum kesinlikle beni çarpmıştı Çünkü
tam anlamıyla ve kendine bir yol çizmek
için artık galiba ufak ufak bir karar
vermeye başlamıştım
sonra sonra devlet tiyatrosundan gelen
bir tane sanatçı abimiz dedi ki biz
devlet tiyatrosunda bir çocuk oyunu
yapıyoruz Arkada da 3 küçük roller var
bunu oynar mısınız Hatta iki tane de çok
sevdiğim hala görüş arkadaşımla beraber
biz de evet Tiyatrosu'nda bir anda
kendimizi işte herhalde 10 sınıfta
şimdiki şeyle denkleştirdiğimde 10
sınıfta devlet tiyatrosunda arka tarafta
figürasyon yaparken
bulduk ve orada Tabii büyük sanatçılarla
Evet Tiyatrosu sanatçılarıyla tanışmaya
başladım ve ve anladım ki aslında bütün
benim O hayal ettiğim benim orada olmak
istediğim şey pek de kolay olabilecek
bir şey değil Çünkü insanlar yıllarını
vermişler çalışmışlar hala çalışmaya
devam ediyorlar ve çalışmaya devam
ettikçe sahnede ve ayakta kalabiliyorlar
Bunların içinde de hala hepinizin de çok
sevdiği çok değerli sanatçılar var ve
onlarla beraber çalışmaya imkanı buldum
ve bir gün dedim ki Ben de
konservatuvara gireceğim yani bu işi
yapacağım Çünkü ben sahnede olmaktan çok
mutlu oluyordum burada olup insanlara
hayatın
başka bir formunu insanlara ulaştırarak
O ulaştırdığım formla hayal güçlerini
açıp onlara yeni yollar çizmek yeni bir
yolculuğa çıkartmak büyüsü beni
gerçekten beni benden almıştı ve dedim
ki konservatuara gireceğim ben de Oyuncu
olacağım konservatora girmek için de
hatta lisans yani 11 10 sınıfta falan
karar vermiştim Hatta Çünkü 11 sınıfta
işte sınavlara çalışmak için dershaneler
falan başladığında aileme dedim ki ben
gitmeyeceğim haberiniz olsun Çünkü ben
konservatuvara gireceğim Tabii ki büyük
bir tepkiyle karşılaştım
Burası benim için önemli çünkü
ailemi ikna etmem gerekti
tiyatrocu olmak için Çünkü tiyatro
ülkemizde maalesef aslında Çok da kolay
hayatınızı idare ettirebileceğiniz bir
meslek değil kazanca anlamında
söylüyorum sanatta çok kolay bir şey
değil ama ben burada
Benim geleceğimi ve benim
hayatımı kendi başıma idame ettirmemiz
sağlığımı isteyen anneme ve babama beni
o güne kadar getirmiş eğitmiş okutmuş
olan Anneme babama kendimi ispatlamak
zorundaydım onlara Evet ben
konservatuvara gireceğim çünkü bunu
yapacağım Çünkü bunu yapacağım Çünkü
bunu yapacağım demek zorundaydım ve bunu
demek de Hepiniz de Belki şu anda
yaşıyorsunuz böyle şeyler İstediğiniz
bir meslek var ve bu konuda ailenizi
ikna etmek zorundasınız zorundasınız
Çünkü
gerçekten de önce kendinizi İkna etmiş
oluyorsunuz Aslında ailenize kendinizi
ikna ederken istediğiniz şeyin ne kadar
çok istediğinizi birilerine göstermek
zorundasınız önce kendinize kendinizi
ispatla aldıktan sonra zaten insanlar da
anneniz babanızda bunu görecektir ve ben
dedim ki gelin devlet tiyatrosunda benim
bir oyunum var Hatta şöyle oldu o çocuk
oyunundaki başarımız sayesinde
azizesinin Yaşar Ne Yaşar Ne Yaşamaz
işlerini bileyim Ee Tümer Selçuk'un
abdulcambaz ve 4 Murat gibi oyunlarında
da gene eski AKM'nin büyük salonunda
sahneye çıkar olmaya başlamıştım ve
aileme ben birer bilet götürdüm davetiye
götürdüm beni izler misiniz lütfen diye
Sağ olsunlar onlar geldiler Hatta
geldikleri bütün o biraz önce söylediğim
o önemli
tiyatroculardan dedim ki annemle babam
geliyor ve sizlerle tanıştırmak
istiyorum bunun içinde zafer al göz var
resumru Yavrucuk var daha pek çok çok
önemli tiyatrolar şu anda sizinle
severek beğenerek izlediğiniz tiyatrolar
var dedim ki onlarla konuşur musunuz
Yani ben bu işler neden istiyorum ne
kadar istiyorum burada nasıl çalışıyorum
ve benden olur mu yani çünkü bu çok
önemli bir Kriter onlar da dediler ki
neden olmasın Elbette ki yapabiliriz Ve
Bizimkiler geldiler oyunu izlediler
oyunu izledikten sonra kollarından tuttu
mahkemede bir borsa vardı borsa
restoranda birer çay ısmarladım ve o
arada da Zafer abi geldi sağ olsun sonra
abla geldi Daha neşen Abi vardı işte
İştar gökseven vardı ve 4 kişi
sağ olsunlar gelip şunu anlattılar
annemle babama Engin bu işi çok istiyor
istediği kadar da Aslında emek veriyor
ve çalışıyor ve çalıştıkça da burada
daha fazla verimi artıyor ve biz
konservatuar parçalarını bile şimdiden
izledik bizce şu anda girse kazanır gibi
bir şey söylediler aileme ve ben eve
döndüğümde bir daha bir masaya oturduk
ve dediler ki istiyor musun Evet
istiyorum yapacak mısın Evet yapacağım
peki dediler ve Sağ olsunlar ben onları
önce kendime sonra onları ikna ettikten
sonra
iyi bir aile iyi bir örnek olarak da
benim arkama geçtiler ve beni
desteklemeye başladılar ve ben o günden
itibaren ailemle birlikte kendi
geleceğimi belirlemek için konseratör
sınavlarına çalıştım
ve çok şükür ki hem İstanbul
Üniversitesi Hem maddi bir üniversitesin
bütün sınavların hepsini kazandım ve
neredeyse 18 yaşında üniversite
seçebilir hale gelmiştim hatta hatta
Bazı arkadaşlarım daha İşte bizim o
zamanlar Şimdiki olduğu gibi ikinci
sınava henüz gir ben üniversiteyi
kazanmıştım bile İstanbul
Üniversitesi'nde Yıldız Kenter'in
başında olduğu rahmet yıldızkender'in
başında oldu ve Evimize çok yakın bir
konservatuardı ve ben o konservatuarda
çalışmaya
konservatuarda okumaya başladım şimdi
önemli bir adım atmıştım Aslında
üniversiteye Ama gördüm ki hani ben
oraya girince Hani sanatçı oldum oldu
Tamam bak etraf çok güzel bütün her şey
tam hayal ettiğim gibi olacak diye
düşünürken aynı hayatımızda da
karşılaşacağımız gibi işte hayal ettiğim
gibi olmadı anladım ki orada daha fazla
çalışmaya ihtiyacım var çünkü orada da
büyük bir rekabet var çünkü orada da çok
sevdiğim arkadaşlarımla beraber
çıktığımız bir yolculuk var ve kendimizi
ispat etmemiz gereken hocalarımız var ve
çok değerli hocalarımız var içinde
Haldun dormen'in Yıldız Kenter'in Mehmet
Peker'in Suat özturanı falan olduğu Son
derece değerli insanların onayını
almanız lazım ve Devam etmeniz lazım ve
şöyle bir anım oldu bir anda ilginç bir
şey yaşadım Kent tiyatrosunda da o ara
Yıldız Kenter Rusya'dan bir yönet
getirmiş Benim de tanıdığım bildiğim çok
değerli bir yönetmen
Martı oyununu Çehov Martı oyunu sahneye
koyacak ve ben orada çok olmak istiyorum
çünkü inanılmaz bir kadrosu var işte
Yıldız Kenter oynuyormuş bir Kenter
oynuyor Şükran Güngör Köksal'ın 2 gün
önce maalesef kaybettiğimiz Köksal
abimiz oynuyor Tilbe saran gibi çok
değerli sanatçılar ve orada olmalıyım ve
3 tane de Rol var ufak işte arkadan
geçiyor Bir tanesi gitar çalıyor bir
tanesi de hizmetçi oynayacak orada
olmalıyım ve orada olmak için ne yapmam
gerekiyor Ne yapmam gerekiyor diye
düşünürken bir oda işin yapılacağı
Haberi geldi yani bir seçme yapılacak
Hatta yönetmen okulumuza gelecek
okulumuzda da bir seçmede de
öğrencilerden de birkaç tanesini seçecek
ve provaları alacak
Neyse bunu bu ölümü çok uzatmıyorum
geldi okulumuza seçme yapıldı ve ben
kazanamadım onu seçmeyi iki tane üç tane
arkadaşım seçildi ve biz böyle okulda
kaldık Ben dedim ki ne yapacağım şimdi
yani orada olmak istiyorum
Çünkü açıkçası orada öğreneceğimi
düşünüyorum ve orada devam edeceğini
düşünüyorum Evet burası bir
konservatuvar Evet Hayallerim
Hayallerimi gerçekleştirdim ama şimdi
yeni hayallerim var şimdi o hayalleri
gerçekleştirmeliyim Onun için ne
yapacağım bir şey yapmalıyım bir şey
yapmalıyım
prova'nın gününü saatini öğrendim Kenter
tiyatrosunda pazartesi günü sabah 10'da
prova var Ben saat 9'da tiyatronun
Kapısından girdim gittim oraya oturdum
Yıldız ucu geldi gördü beni dedi ki
Enginciğim Ne yapıyorsun hocam prova
izleyeceğim Ben dedim Engin okulun var
dedi farkındayım dedim ben okulumu
Müsadenizle kırıyorum gitmeyeceğim okula
Çünkü burada daha çok şey öğreneceğimi
düşünüyorum çünkü burada olmak istiyorum
Eğer ki bunun benim için bir karşılığı
olacaksa dersten kalacaksam sınıfta da
kalacaksam ben kalmaya razıyım bu konuda
sizin için bir sorun var mı dedim Baktı
bana şöyle bir hiç böyle bir tepki
beklemiyordum Çünkü birazcık açıkçası
şey yani Dominant bir öğretmendi Yıldız
Hanım ve dolayısıyla Peki senin tercihin
sen bilirsin kalabilirsin Elbette
teşekkür ederim dedi çünkü işte burada
gene küçücük bir parantez var istemek
orada olmak ve sonuna kadar da arkasında
durmakla ilgili ve mutlu olduğunuz yerle
ilgili bir şeyi aslında galiba Ben
Hocama ispat edebilmiştim
hemen uzatmıyorum öyle bir şey yaşandı
ki bir buçuk iki hafta sonra ben her
sabah orada bir yarım saat önceden
oturup Beklerken bir buçuk iki hafta
sonra sahnede bir prova yapılıyor bir
küçük Rol var işte ya
bir abimiz oynuyor yapması gereken de
çok küçük provada bir şey var Onu da
hatta canlandırayım size bir küçük sahne
varsa sahnenin ortasından da bir kapak
açılıyor ve bu kapak açıldıktan sonra
Martı Gibi
ne bağırması lazım rol bu kadar
yapılması gereken şey tek bu Bizde böyle
izliyoruz bakalım ne yapacak abimizi
falan filan diye abimiz kapı açıyor hep
diyor bu diyor falan yapamadım özür
dilerim diyor falan ya Allah Allah niye
yapmıyor acaba diyorum martı sesi işte
hepimizin yapabileceği bir şey aslında
sonra bir ikinci gün Gene olmadı dedi ki
ben bunu biraz evde çalışabilir miyim
dedi falan biz anlamadık martesini evde
çalışacak Peki ne güzel Biz de uzaktan
izliyoruz böyle yani Hiç oturuyoruz 3
gün prova'ya gelmedi
gelmeyince Nerede bu adam niye gelmedi
telefonlar falan açılmıyor sonradan
anlaşıldı ki aslında Evet gerçekten
sahnede var olmak hiç kolay bir şey
değil küçücük bir şey yapabilmek bile
çok zor bir şey Kendisi de bunu anladığı
için aslında Zaten profesyonel olarak da
oyuncu değildi bırakma kararı almış O An
şöyle bir şey yaşandı
Yıldızı şöyle bir arkasını döndü ve dedi
ki Şimdilik dedi abimizin yerine ismini
vermeyeceğim abinizin yerine kim markete
ister dediğinde ben zaten o ara
ayaktaydım o böyle duruyordum beni
direkt gördük gel bakalım dedi Ben
geçtim işte ne bileyim hani tabii ki o
an bu an göstereceğim Yani neyi
göstereceğim martı sesi yapabilmeyi
göstereceğim peki öyle bir martısı çıktı
ki içimden sanki özümde bir martı varmış
gibi
bir süre sonra böyle bir Hani öyle bir
de hatta oyunculardan da böyle Gülenler
oldu sağ olsun Tilbe abla çok çok
destekleyicidir zaten her zaman Tilbe
saran Onlar da çok güldüler falan ertesi
gün gene gel inşallah gelmez diyorum
yani gelmez ki ben burada kalırım falan
gerçekten gelmedi Ben ikinci gün biraz
daha böyle nasıl bir özgüvense o o büyük
aktörlerin arasında kendimce şov
yapıyorum falan Neyse güzel tepkiler de
alıyorum derken 3 gün 4 gün 5 gün derken
rol bana kaldı ve gerçekten de aslında
tam da istediğim şeyi kendi çabamla
mutlu olacağım yere galiba kendimi
getirmiş oldum ve bir Kenter Tiyatrosu
macerası başladı ve ben çalışmaya devam
ettim
turnelere gittik Üniversite 3
sınıftaydım daha sonra 4 sınıfta Yıldız
hoca tarafından Yani yine aynı tiyatroda
bir başka oyunun Yıldız hocamla paylaşma
teklifi aldım ki bu hayatımda aldım en
büyük en önemli teklifti ki oradan
itibaren
önümdeki örnekle Tabii Yıldız Kenter'in
çalışma temposu ve Hani bir an bile
hayattaki Bir boşluğu bile
havada bırakmayan bir öğretmen olarak
bana bir şeyleri anlatmaya başlamıştı
zaten öğretmeye de çoktan başlamıştı
zaten Ve bir
15 sene kadar sürebilecek bir
birliktelik yaşadık kendisiyle Bu süre
içerisinde gerçekten 27 İlla 28 arasında
prodüksiyonun birebir var oldum bunların
18-19 tanesinde bizzat oyuncu olarak var
oldum bu süre içerisinde işte bir anda
Kenter tiyatrosunda sahneye çıkmamla
televizyondaki yapımcılar beni görmeye
başladılar Sonra işte reklamlar çekmeye
başladım Sonra dublaj yapmaya başladım
ve anladım ki Ee çalıştıkça kendimi
gösterdikçe mutlu oluyorum Mutlu oldukça
daha fazla üretiyorum daha fazla
ürettikçe daha fazla mutlu oluyorum ve
bunu bir yaşam biçimi haline getirdim
güzel arkadaşlarım söylemek istediğim
tek şey var Ne yaparsınız yapın
Mesleğiniz ne olursa olsun hayattan ne
istiyorsanız isteyin lütfen mutlu
olacağınız yeri mutlu olacağınız anı
arayın da bulun Çünkü iş olsun diye
yapacağınız bir iş sizi mutlu
etmeyecekse emin olun başarı
kazanamayacaksınız Onun için başarılı
olmanın bana kalırsanız bir numaralı
kuralı önce çalışmaktan ve sonra o
çalışmanın da mutluluğundan geçiyor ben
yıllar sonra kendi Tiyatrosu da aldıktan
sonra rahmetli hocamızla kaybettikten
sonra kendi tiyatromu kurdum tiyatro
ismiyle bu sene 10 senesinde şimdiye
kadar 7 tane Prodüksiyon yaptım şu an 3
tanesini oynuyoruz akciğer anne ve daha
yeni geçen hafta premierini yaptığımız
Kim bu ven adlı oyunumuzu oynamaya devam
ediyoruz artık Yönetmenlik de yapıyorum
kendimce
büyük prodüksiyonları artık hayal etmeye
başladım Umarım ileride sizlerle beraber
onlara da Tanık olursunuz Ama tek
bildiğim bir şey var ki ben çok
bu işi yaparken mutlu bir adamım ve
anladım ki mutlu oldukça daha iyi
yapmaya başlıyorum Daha iyi yaptıkça da
daha çok üretmeye başlıyorum
yani nacizane söyleyebileceğim tek bir
şey var o ilk başına şöyle bir dönelim
Hadi konuyu şöyle bir bağlayalım
isterseniz o Haylaz çocuğun ders kırmak
için girdiği tiyatro kolundan Aslında
galiba şu anda kendi ayaklarımda
üzerinde durabilen arkasında 20-25 tane
insanı çalıştırıp birlikte sanat
üretebilen ülkemizdeki
tiyatro sektörüne diyeyim yepyeni
metinler kazandıran dünya tiyatrolarında
neler oynanıyorsa gidiyorum izliyorum ve
onları çevrelerini yaparak ülkemizdeki
tiyatro severlerle buluşturmaya
çalışıyorum böyle bir Misyonu kendimce
üstlenen bir yere gelmiş oldum kısacık
bir hikaye Tabii ki süren bittiği için
kapatmak zorundayım 15 dakika içerisinde
Bunlar sığıyor Ama ben çok mutluyum
çalıştığım için çok mutluyum çok mutlu
olduğum için de çalışmaya devam edeceğim
hepinize kolay gelsin Teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]